you candle there's a special reason why
giving back to the military veterans is
a top priority for Finley automotive
here's a little history lesson and more
on how the local company continues to
support our heroes Tyler how you doing
I'm great Rock it's good to see you good
to see you as always and of course you
know I love Finley automotive for what
they do for the community as well as the
car park for you guys let's talk about
what you guys are doing for military
vets here locally well we we love to
support our vets we have a special
fondness for anybody that served our
country and you know we were kind of our
roots Pete Finley way back was a a
fighter pilot in World War two and when
he got back from World War two he opened
a gas station in his hometown of panaka
Nevada and I started reconditioning cars
which led to selling used cars which led
to opening a used-car lot Las Vegas
which led to getting an Oldsmobile
franchise and that was a start of Finley
automotive so we got to feel like our
roots go back to the military and we
love to support our veterans this is a
great story what are some of the ways
that you guys are supporting this well
one of the most recent just in the last
week or so we partnered up with Wells
Fargo banks and the military warrior
support foundation and we we donated a
Kia Sedona to a veteran who had earned a
Purple Heart in Afghanistan and he Steve
and Stanley's his name came back to Las
Vegas has a large family with eight kids
needed a van so we teamed up to donate a
Kia Sedona van to Steve and Stanley
which was flat which was a fun thing to
do
so Honor Flight is a great organization
that honors veterans by flying them back
to Washington DC giving a tour of the
money that's giving them a medal
honoring them for them to their service
and we've supported them for the last
few years and it's great to see these a
lot of them our world World War two now
it's movie it's mostly Korean War
veterans but to see them get honored for
their service so we love to support them
the challenges right now they can't fly
they can't take these these guys back so
the flights are kind of on hold
right now so one of the things we're
doing is honor flights got ahold of us
the other day and they're gonna do a
drive-by parade for a veteran who's
turning 90 here next week and so we're
getting a bunch of our dealerships
together and we're getting a bunch of
old cars we're gonna participate in a
drive-by parade honor this this little
veteran on his 90th birthday and any
other one we support his veterans
village which has been really as an
institution here in Las Vegas providing
housing for veterans and you know the
thing is we don't want any veteran to
ever be homeless and so Veterans Village
provides housing and support and they
team up with other agencies that we
support like care complex to make sure
they get food and the goal is to get
these these people you know the respect
that they deserve a place to live and
and way to get by and life and honor
them for their service so we love to
support veterans village we love to
support honor flights and we employ a
lot of veterans and it's just something
that's kind of close to our heart
contact Finley automotive if you'd like
to join that special vets birthday car
parade on July 23rd we want to thank
Finley automotive group for being one of
our community pride partners Leslie